[Music]
Physical Strength Where were you and what were you doing on the night of April 8, 1525? This is a very
interesting question, but it was so interesting that sometimes a dragon,
not a snake, would
come out of the bushes you poked.What do you
know?
Here's what you're doing, answering questions with questions.
Darius Grenville Was it me from the beginning? I
can't believe that woman's help is still there. I just want to thank you for your continued support.  Give me that same night seven years ago,
Darius Glenn, who I continued to hate. Be
with me Bill. Let's get
started. The distance between us is already one step at a time. I love you,
Glenn Bill. Don't think that, my
opponent's skill with the sword is far greater than mine.  Surpass
[Music]
Even if I repeat it,
I will probably be cut and defeated in most of those encounters.This
future is one of them.The future is not
decided.If
perfect prediction is impossible, there will
always be a future in which I win.  All I have to do is
find the unbroken thread, and
from the moment I observe it, the
future pulls me
towards it.Towards the observed future, the torrent of the time axis
washes away my existence, and just like that flow, my
hand sends out
[Music]  It would
n't have been suspicious to just
stand there, I could have just run away, but
why?
That magic sword that was supposed to be lost was something that
you took from my mother along with the woman's life seven years ago, and it was something that I
couldn't take away.  Yes, that's the answer. You
can't see that woman. I don't
think they look alike, but that's fine. You
know that, but
the spells in the movie can only recreate the pain that you know. So
please rest assured.
7 years ago  I have relived every single one of the 128 shoes you gave my mother that night.